a good thing going right now too so
they're going to make sure he's fully
ready before he comes back and weissman
has yet to scrimmage yet so on the
screen you can't see this right now but
we have a
image of ray allen steph curry and
reggie miller at center court with spike
lee so we know a lot of steph's friends
and family and former players are going
to be there at msg who else should we
expect to see tonight
well this is this is a so now that i can
see steph i feel like i can say this on
the air without spoiling it um there's
going to be a lot of surprises with him
his dad obviously um is going to be
there
and i know aisha is not able to make it
tonight but
as you see ray allen also his college
coach from davidson college bob mckillop
is surprising him and flying in so i was
i didn't know if i was allowed to say
that live right now but now that i know
steph is not watching nba tv at this
moment i don't feel too bad
he did tell me that there was two people
that really believed in me it was my dad
to cover the nba and be around the nba i
mean when you look at that you know if
you
if if you know those three guys and you
know the history of the game
you know it's almost you know it it's
one of these emotional moments that they
kind of bring tears to you